Bộ cửa trung đảng, mang hành kèm theo quy định một chiếm người hay không hay tư của bán chất hành trung đảng, khoa mề bà.
Gió tổ bị thương tồ lâm, kỹ bà hành emu người thử người nằm hành hành hành thông trong hay tư.
Về bộ cửa đàn hôi đã biểu tòan phút, gió đại hội quyết.
Về bộ cửa trung đảng, giữ dẫn theo quyền tắt tập trung đàn trủ, bị đảng, trước tiết, đa số qua bán.
Thuyến thức bò phía kính được thực hiện trong nhiều trường hợp.
Trong đo á dụ, khi bộ bán chất hành trung đảng, bộ bộ chiếm chiếm tổ mỹ thử.
Bán mề thử, các nhiều hành emu bà, kai tư, kai làm trong trường bốn tại quy định một chiếm người hay tư.
quy định trình tờ, vụ tổ bầu cửa bộ chiếm chiếm bán mề thử, tổ mỹ thử của thệ như sau.
Điều hành emu bà, bộ bộ chiếm chiếm tổ mùa, phía nó tương nhất của bán chất hành trung đảng.
Gió đồng chiế tổ bị thương qua trước, tải cửa, khoa không, tải cửa làm chiếm tổ viên.
Khai mặt và chủ trí cho đến khi bầu sau, bán chủ tế khối ghi.
Trường hợp đồng chiế tổ, mỹ thử qua trước, không thể làm chiếm tổ viên.
Tí bán chủ tệnh đại hội cửa trường tổ viên.
Hai, bán chủ tế khối ghi, bán chất hành trung đảng.
Bảo cáo về đean và đean giống số lượng, bộ chiếm chiếm cân bầu.
Bà, hội ghi thảo lợp, biểu quyết bệ số lượng, bộ chiếm chiếm chiếm.
Bảo cáo, hội ghi thảo lợp, bà, bán chủ tếnh tổ, hợp, răng xách những người tự ứng cửa được đean giống cho nữ trần ở đường rút.
Bà không được giúp hỏi răng xách bộ cửa.
Đồng chiếm tổ viên thay mặt bán chủ tệnh hội y y bán chất hành trung đảng.
Bảo cáo về đean và đean giống lượng, bán bị thư cân bầu.
Hai, hội ghi thảo lợp, biểu quyết thông qua về số lượng, bán bị thư.
Bà, bán chủ tệnh bảo cáo, răng xách những lộng chiếm được bán chất hành trung đảng.